bonsoir je vais vous parler de l'école
du futur de l'école dans 25 ans essayait
de l'imaginer avec vous et on a
travaillé avec plusieurs personnes sur
les scénarios pour l'école dans 25 ans
et je vais vous présenter un des
scénarios je vais pas vous les présenter
les présenter tous un sérieux un
scénario un peu extrême quand on essaye
de comprendre ce qui va se passer dans
25 ans une façon de faire c'est de
regarder le monde tel qu'il était il ya
25 ans et les outils que nous utilisons
et à 25 ans on ne sait pas si vous vous
souvenez mais à 25 ans vous aviez pas
l'arrêt ce mail vous utilisiez pas
internet
vous aviez pas de compte facebook vous
allez pas lire sur wikipédia
et c'est le monde a complètement changé
en 25 ans de ce point de vue là une
façon qui est sans doute unique dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
une étude qui a été conduite aux états
unis qui montre qu'un américain moyen
aujourd'hui passent à peu près quatre
heures et demie par jour à lire il ya 40
ans un américain moyen mettait une heure
et demie par jour à lire comparé à
l'invention de l'écriture il ya 5000 ans
l'accélération du temps passé à lire est
absolument fabuleuse et ça on le doit à
ces outils là et moi ya 25 ans j'ai
décidé de m'intéresser à ces outils là
et pour une question précise c est ce
que ces outils peuvent apporter quelque
chose à l'apprentissage
j'ai commencé à faire une thèse de
doctorat sur ce sujet là absolument
persuadé que ces outils allait nous
apporter énormément de choses que j'ai
commencé à faire des expériences et des
expériences qui ont raté puis j'ai
persévéré
effet notre expérience et j'ai
systématiquement raté toutes les
expériences que j'ai fait dans ce
domaine là et dans le laboratoire dans
lequel je travaillais pour ma thèse de
doctorat
les collègues se sont un peu mieux
appeler effet tricot de mon nom si
l'expérience pirates mais ça va pas
découragé j'ai décidé de continuer puis
j'ai commencé à former des enseignants
au milieu des années 1990 en leur
expliquant parce que ce qu'on leur
expliquait à l'époque un que le
numérique ça allait être formidable et
que ça allait à bouleverser l'école puis
j'ai été pas mal l'entreprise qui
investissait massivement dans le
e-learning et qui globalement ne faisait
que perdent leur argent en investissant
dans les learning plus a expliqué
essentiellement pourquoi ils perdaient
leur argent j'étais bien incapable de
leur proposer autre chose
puis j'ai commencé à former des
chercheurs essaient leur transmettre ma
passion pour ces outils numériques et
mon talon pour rater des expériences
bien jouera à marseille
je suis allée une thèse qui portait sur
l'utilisation des vidéos par les
entraîneurs de football
ça au moins c'est un sujet intéressant
et notamment sur des apprentissages
tactique et la membre du jury de thèse
je lis la thèse et en exergue de cette
thèse il y avait une citation
les livres seront bientôt obsolète dans
les écoles cette citation sais pas si
vous savez de qui elle est elle est de
thomas edison
elle date de 1913
mais cette citation elle m'a donné un
vertige absolument incroyable je me suis
dit mais finalement ce que thomas edison
croyez en 1913
c'est exactement ce que moi je croyais
au début des années 1990 les thomas
edison s'est complètement planté et
peut-être que je suis en train de me
planter complètement ce qui est
intéressant c'est que commencer du sol
n'avait pas compris à quel point le
cinéma allait devenir important dans
notre culture dans d'autres formes
d'expression artistique
à quel point elle est bouleversée
notre société mais pas compris non plus
que le cinéma allait à peu près rien
apporté à l'école
n'allez pas trouver de place au sein de
l'école mais par contre les livres
continuerez d'y occuper toute leur place
donc à partir de là je me suis dit mais
peut-être que tu es en train de courir
après un nuage
tu te poses une question qui n'est pas
la bonne question mais j'ai commencé à
essayer de ne pas de me poser de bonnes
questions
en gros je me suis conscient de dire
avant de me demander à quoi peuvent
servir les outils faudrait d'abord
savoir à quoi sert l'école et ça c'est
une bonne question à quoi sert l'école
dont beaucoup de gens quand on leur pose
cette question au 10 mai l'école ça sert
à apprendre mais je suis pas du tout sûr
que ça serve as à l'école regardez cette
petite vidéo
ou pas
g
ah bon
même pas
l'intérêt
okada
prix que cette petite fille qui est pas
bien nager dans sa vie très courte
elle a pris des choses fabuleusement
complexe elle a appris à interagir 1
avec un outil avec lequel mon propre
père n'arrive pas à interagir alors que
je lui explique patiemment pendant des
heures et elle essaie même de faire
quelque chose de fabuleux elle essaie de
transférer un mode d'interaction d'un
outil vers un autre donc les humains
vous voyez ils sont capables d'apprendre
très jeunes des choses très complexe
absolument fabuleuse ils n'ont pas
besoin d'aller à l'école pour ça l'école
elle sert par apprendre quand on essaie
de comprendre en regardant différents
pays et différentes époques passées à
l'école l'école elle sert
essentiellement à apprendre des
connaissances qui ne sont pas utiles qui
ne sont pas utiles au moment où on les
apprend qu'ils seront utiles plus tard
parce que si vous avez une connaissance
vraiment utile pour tous les jours vous
l'apprendrez tout seul
si vous avez une connaissance par
exemple la manipulation en un objet que
vous manipulez tous les jours vous
pouvez très bien la prendre tout seul
par l'action par le tâtonnement par
l'exploration l'école elle sert passez
les sous de l'école sert à apprendre le
futur
après je me suis posé la question qui
est maintenant que j'ai compris à peu
près à quoi servait l'école essayons de
comprendre à quoi qu'est ce qui fait que
les enfants les élèves apprennent bien à
l'école qu'est ce qui fait qu'une école
est efficace et là il ya tout un tas de
résultats absolument
comment dire consensuel ce récital à
l'école elle marche à partir du moment
où on arrive à mobiliser l'attention des
élèves à partir du moment où les élèves
sont motivés ces tarifs comprennent
pourquoi ils apprennent ils ont
suffisamment confiance en eux pour
apprendre à l'école elle est efficace
quand on fait faire des choses aux
élèves qui sont pertinentes pour les
apprentissages canton réguler leur
apprentissage être l'école elle est
efficace quand on arrive à faire
apprendre les élèves progressivement à
la faire franchir des étapes en partant
de là où ils sont pour les amener là où
on veut les amener tout le monde est
d'accord
partout dans le monde là dessus sur ce
qui est important pour réussir à
apprendre à l'école et quand on fait le
tour de ces questions là on trouve aucun
outil ce qui est important pour
apprendre à l'école n'a rien à voir avec
les outils qu'on utilise à l'école et là
j'ai commencé à comprendre pourquoi je
courais après un nuage c'est parce que
je me posais la mauvaise question
l'important c'est pas les outils
l'important c'est ce qu'on fait faire
c'est ce qu'on enseigne comment on
enseigne comment mobilise les élèves
comment focalisent leur attention
alors à partir de là effectivement on
commence à voir à quoi éventuellement
pour être utile des outils je vous
prendre un exemple imaginer qu'un jour
on vous demande d'enseigner à des élèves
le galop du cheval il va falloir vous
fassiez comprendre le galop du cheval on
est d'accord ça sert à rien de savoir ça
donc c'est un bon candidat pour être
enseignée à l'école puisque ça sert à
rien et on va imaginer que vous avez
réussi à attirer l'attention des élèves
ils sont attentifs ils sont intéressés
ils sont motivés vous êtes un super bon
pour enfin vous avez réussi à les
intérêts
c'est à ça et maintenant ce que vous
allez faire puisque vous avez leur
attention la motivation et vous allez
essayer leur faire comprendre on c'est
super difficile à comprendre le galop du
cheval 1 on vous savez que depuis la
grotte chauvet en moins de trente milles
jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle les
humains ont essayé de comprendre le
galop du cheval et vous le savez
jusqu'au milieu xviiie siècle ils ont
absolument rien compris au galop du
phénomène observé un cheval au galop ça
permet pas de comprendre
par contre il ya quelque chose que vous
pouvez faire si vous voulez que les
élèves comprennent le galop du cheval
c'est que vous avez commencé à
décomposer le halo du cheval vous allez
présenter le galop du cheval comme une
succession d'étapes et les élèves vont
comprendre une étape puis une étape une
étape et c'est seulement après avoir
compris chacune de ces étapes qui vont
être capables de comprendre autre chose
comprendre un ralenti comprendre une
représentation du llano du cheval qui va
doucement qui permet de voir ce qu'on ne
voit pas en vitesse réelle et une fois
qu'ils auront compris le ralenti alors
ils seront capables de comprendre un
cheval au galop ils seront capables
d'aller observer la nature pour la
comprendre
et là on voit le rôle les outils les
outils une fois qu'on a conçu notre
progression une soit une fois qu'on sait
par quelle étape on doit passer une fois
qu'on a réussi à mobiliser l'attention à
motiver et cetera bref à donner du sang
qui fâchent ce qu'on essaye de lancer
alors les outils sont fabule alors les
nouvelles technologies permettent de
présenter aux élèves des choses qui sont
extrêmement efficaces pour la
compréhension des choses qui sont
extrêmement efficaces pour l'acquisition
de savoirs faire
des choses qui sont extrêmement
difficiles qu'à ce canton veut enseigner
à distance encore une fois à condition
ne pas oublier qu'on est d'abord là pour
mobiliser l'attention gérer la
motivation construire des progressions
etc
il ya d'autres domaines dans lesquels
ces outils sont fabuleux c'est
l'adaptation pour des enfants et des
adolescents et des jeunes adultes qui
sont en situation de handicap qui sont
porteurs de troubles
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui grâce aux
outils dont on dispose on peut pour un
enfant aveugle lui faire explorer une
image soit actuellement soit par retour
de son on est capable de faire percevoir
des images à des enfants qui a
simplement 20 ans avait énormément de
mal à percevoir des images mais c'est
pas tellement ça c'est qu'on peut leur
faire percevoir n'importe quelle image
du monde
aujourd'hui grâce à des outils comme ça
donc ces outils sont absolument fabuleux
à partir du moment où on comprend qu'ils
ne sont que des outils donc je crois que
l'école dans 25 ans elle ressemblera
beaucoup à l'école aujourd'hui c'est
clair que l'essentiel ressemblera
beaucoup à l'école d'aujourd'hui
l'essentiel c'est ce qui se passe entre
des êtres humains
mais après une fois que c'est essentiel
sera là une fois qu'on sort à le mettre
en oeuvre
alors les outils pourront apporter
énormément mais ils apporteront
énormément à partir du moment où on leur
laissera cette place août
voilà je vous remercie